anteriormente hemos visto que un vector
se define por su magnitud y por su
dirección y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es que tengamos un poco de
práctica
calculando o averiguando la magnitud de
este vector y que ahora lo tenemos aquí
dibujado en este plano cartesiano y
bueno lo que queremos averiguar es su
magnitud entonces te encargó que pausa
el vídeo y veas si puedes averiguar lo
bien recordando la magnitud de un vector
es bueno simplemente la longitud de esta
línea azul y es por eso que la podemos
obtener como la distancia entre el punto
inicial y el punto final de un vector
así que una forma de pensarlo es decir
que esta magnitud de este vector o esta
magnitud
va a ser igual y bueno la podemos
obtener con la fórmula de la distancia
que esencialmente sale del teorema de
pitágoras y dice que la magnitud de este
vector es igual a la raíz cuadrada
a la raíz cuadrada del cambio en x del
cambio en x es decir delta de x esto
elevado al cuadrado más el cambio en
james esto elevado al cuadrado delta de
y elevado al cuadrado y una vez más
recuerda que este triángulo que tengo
aquí el cual se llama delta es una forma
de abreviar el cambio en este caso en x
y en este caso en 10 y de nuevo
observamos que estamos usando la fórmula
de la distancia la cual viene del
teorema de pitágoras y esto se va a ser
mucho más evidente cuando dibujen el
cambio y el cambio en x en este plano
cartesiano así que vamos a hacerlo cuál
va a ser nuestro cambio en jr
bueno pues observa que nuestro punto
inicial el valor que toma quien es 9 y
vamos a bajar hasta el valor que toma y
en el punto final el cual es
y hasta aquí lo que quiere decir que
lleva a pasar de 9 a 2 y entonces
podemos decir que el cambio en james va
a ser igual a menos 7 bajamos 7 unidades
y de manera similar para el cambio en x
vamos a empezar con x igualados y vamos
a ir hasta x igual a 5 así que el cambio
en la dirección horizontal es delta de x
igual a 3 recuerda que podemos ver a
esta como la componente horizontal de
este vector y tiene a delta de x igual a
3 y ahora date cuenta que aquí estoy
dibujando un triángulo rectángulo y por
ende podemos usar el teorema de
pitágoras para obtener la longitud de la
hipotenusa aunque seguramente estás
pensando en esperar la longitud de un
lado de un triángulo no puede darme un
valor negativo pero es justo por eso que
al elevarlo al cuadrado esto tiene
sentido porque no importa si estás
tomando un valor de menos 7 de 7
ambos te darán un valor positivo justo
aquí y bueno si tú realmente piensas en
esto como un triángulo por lo único que
necesitas preocuparte es por observar la
longitud de este lado que tenemos aquí o
por la magnitud de este lado del
triángulo lo cual será el valor absoluto
de esta cantidad y así nos dará el
número positivo 7 muy bien entonces
diremos que esto va a ser igual va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada y vamos a
sustituir delta de x vale 3
entonces me va a quedar 3 al cuadrado lo
cual es 9 + delta de y la cual es menos
7 y cuando la elevamos al cuadrado me da
a 49 positivo y una vez más tú puedes
ver a este como el cambio de jeff
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es menos 7
elevado al cuadrado y esto te va a dar
49 y lo puedes ver como la longitud de
este lado del triángulo lo cual es el
valor absoluto de menos 7 porque no
podemos pensar en un lado
que tenga una longitud negativa verdad
el signo negativo lo único que nos está
indicando es la dirección del punto
inicial al punto final de este vector es
decir que vamos de arriba hacia abajo
pero si decimos que la longitud de esto
es 7 y usamos el teorema de pitágoras el
resultado de elevarlo al cuadrado
también nos va a dar 49 así que en ambos
casos esto va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 9 + 49 lo cual es 51
y ya está este radical no creo que se
pueda simplificar mucho y por eso lo voy
a dejar así muy bien ya tenemos lo que
buscábamos la magnitud de este vector 1
es la raíz cuadrada de 58